as you know pretty much every popular
dating book that's been written over the
past 30 years
from the rules to
ignore the guy get the guy to why men
love [ __ ] that they all revolve
around a very complicated version of
playing hard to get
um and look i i wasn't dating in 1950
maybe playing hard to get worked really
really well back then and i'm not saying
it didn't
but i do believe that
nowadays and i actually think to a
certain extent even before the metoo
[Music]
movement that playing hard to get has
become harder and harder and i mean
think about it this way that that
if you're a guy at a party
and you're talking to a woman
and she seems disinterested
the correct response is not to assume
she's playing hard to get and wants you
to keep at it the correct response is to
leave her alone
so if you have all these all these
dating book
gurus like the rules
ladies
telling women and i think in one of
their books they actually say explicitly
don't act so interested treat them like
a guy you don't like
well that's not going to work nowadays
and i'm not saying that to defend the
men
i'm saying this
to give an advantage to women because if
you as a single woman know
that guys are going to be more hesitant
and more reluctant to make the first
move
wow you have a huge built-in advantage
over other women who are sitting back
and waiting and waiting and waiting and
waiting for the guy they like to step up
because those women are playing by the
old rules and you're playing by the new
rules yeah i mean this is this is the
wild thing and i really feel for young
guys now that are coming up i was on a
night out not long ago with one of my
friends young dude real successful guy
big youtube channel
university degree prestigious uni all
this stuff we were on a night out and i
was like oh there's a group of girls
over there why don't we go up and talk
to them i'm not bored of your crack i'm
bored of what you've got to say to me
like why don't we go go up and talk to
them and he he looked like i'd suggested
that we go and like pour their drink
over their head couldn't believe the
fact that i was suggesting that we go up
and speak to a girl no i would never i
would absolutely never what about all of
the me too stuff and that was the first
time that i've ever seen
in real life
you know somebody that's close to me
that has similar values to myself that's
british
show the impact
the fear like complete terror and i
think that you've quoted in the book you
say men used to worry about being
rejected now they're worried about being
labeled a predator
yeah that's a quote from a um
from brian howie who's who who um brian
um
runs kind of a
a comedy
show or or kind of a a a
a dating town hall called um the great
love debate and that was a quote from
brian i mean he does these kind of
dating town halls all across the u.s and
and that was
that was his takeaway but i'm curious
your friend is he younger than you yeah
yeah he's 21 22. yeah yeah i i mean
what's
when i talk to both men and women that
age and that age group i'm always amazed
that there's like this i mean obviously
awkwardness and embarrassment like it's
never a good thing
but i feel like with the
the gen z crowd there is a next level
fear
of saying you're doing the right thing
hypersensitive next like any kind of
awkwardness terrifies them
and
you know i
this doesn't bode well for dating
because dating really involves taking
chances but the good news for women is
that that
my kind of go-to line when i'm
talking about make your move on the
lecture circuit is that men like women
who like them
so
so when a woman takes a chance um
you know striking up a conversation with
a guy
the odds of her having blow back are far
less um
even though she's anxious and she's
worried and she feels the awkwardness
i i i i think the odds of it being a
positive experience are better than for
your your friend or maybe it's all in
our heads but i think even if it is all
in our heads i i just think there are
these huge advantages for women to to
making the first move particularly if
they've already identified the guy they
like
this is the double-edged sword of um the
repercussions of me too into the dating
market i think that i i can sympathize
with the young guys who are lonely
would love to get a girlfriend but are
now terrified of being labeled a
predator
i think that one of the best fixes that
you could have would be for women to
kind of get a firmware update to their
operating system and realize that men
aren't playing by that old set of rules
anymore so the thing is that
women who aren't interested
and women who are interested
are both using the same strategies to
respond to men that approach them
and the men aren't
playing by that set of rules anymore if
you say no to a guy and he's a
respectable guy that's learned from me
too he's going to think oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
hell like i'd better not i better not
push this i don't want to end up on the
the front page of reddit tomorrow
and right but if if you're doing that in
some sort of a strategy to say well if i
say no that's kind of this sexy mental
of [ __ ]
strategy thing i think that explains a
lot about why sort of chatting up and
the circuits of dating are
crumbling a bit
so i had an interesting conversation
with a woman named francesca hoagie who
is a kind of a high-profile dating coach
matchmaker in los angeles and we were
talking about this very thing and here's
what i'm just going to i'm reading from
the book here
she says quote if a woman comes across
as indifferent men will take that as a
sign that she's not interested and will
move on
it's getting to a point that if the
woman doesn't make the first move the
men are not going to this is not the
time to be demure at least not if you're
single and don't want to be single
and i think she's right i mean i'm
obviously i'm generalizing and they're
going to be individual situations that
that play out differently but i'm
writing
you know like
the advice and make your move is macro
not micro and so i can't i can't account
for every individual situation but i i
think what you just described
is spot-on and that there has been this
culture shift and as a result
women who are willing
to make the first move or or at least
make it clear to men
that if the if they make that like just
to open the door wide enough so that the
men know
that that it's safe to walk
an ambiguous signal yeah yeah so i mean
i think like what happens as somebody
who like me who's writing dating books
and telling and sort of pushing out the
idea of women making the first move is
that you get people
from the play hard to get crowd
who
they
they're quick to say oh terrible things
happen to women who make the first move
and they paint this picture that's kind
of like
cruella de vil chasing some poor guy
down the street
and and that's their image of what a
woman making the first move is
and to me
you know a first move by a woman can be
much more subtle what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace